we have some clues to a new character in
the untitled Han Solo movie hey an
Universal dark universe just added two
bizarre new monster movies plus we're
getting you ready to see cars three and
rough night at the movies this weekend a
chaos later all of that is coming on
this week's eg at the movies
[Applause]
the untitled Han Solo movie we know that
tandy Duty was cast in it but we have
not seen her she was not in that initial
cast image well we did get a little more
info she did an interview with Oprah
four varieties actors on actors and had
a little bit more to say so let's take a
look at that to be part of something
legacy like Star Wars
it's loved for a reason I could have
been in it for a brief little yes
nothing and I would have been thrilled
and delighted to be taken seriously a
woman of color 44 years old to be in a
dope-ass you know franchise but it is
you know it's when you just let go my
biggest takeaway from that was her son
could have had a small part but I don't
we don't know what she feel like she
could have CGI monster makeup not
monster well
segue John what do you got monsters I
got some monster now I want to keep
talking about the dark universe I know I
know you have some feelings about it but
uh I want to be excited yes but hold
maybe this will see our business so
director Alex Kurtzman who did the mummy
and is kind of the puppet master of the
universe going forward has revealed two
new movie titles which are the Phantom
of the Opera and the Hunchback of Notre
Thomas so I didn't even know that those
were part of the same playing field yeah
that's because when you think phantom
you think the Android Andrew Lloyd
Webber musical and then when you think
hunchback you think Disney that's what I
that's what my millenia lasting says so
who knows how they're going to fit into
this who knows how they're going to be
set in present-day but
we'll certainly be interested but wait
they have I mean this is Phantom of the
Opera set for like probably 2028 and the
hunchback of notre dom for 2050 anyway
but Chrisman also started naming some
names of people he wants in the
franchise which were Angelina Jolie who
might already be signed on for bride to
Franken yeah yeah yeah I'm here to
Charlize their own Michael Fassbender
and Jennifer Lawrence like Jennifer
Lawrence and she's like 50 years old
well that works even better for my dream
casting for her which is which is gender
flipped Creature from the Black Lagoon
okay so be like essentially to speak in
universal monster properties yeah except
like webbed hands crawling out of a
swamp
yeah because otherwise the way they're
going with this it's going to be another
person who has 80 million franchises
it's going to be good usual well why
don't we move on to our one of our
movies of the week I got - we got it -
first one of them is racing into
theaters on Friday
haha cars three leave the studio get out
I always say there is no bad Pixar movie
but there is a bad Pixar movie and it
cars
- I didn't i've ranked all the Pixar
movies and I like that one always comes
out on Mada hopefully this one can get
it back on track we got all of the car
voices you know and love but a new
director this time knew someone new
behind the camera and some new voices -
we got an army hammer we got Kerry
Washington we have Jeff Gordon played in
the movie yeah please Jeff Gordon
alright someone got paid for that and
that person is a genius
is that person is Jeff Gordon oh my god
I wish anyways you're in the last week
when you quiz me about some trivia
between Brendan Fraser and Tom Cruise
how could I forget your and we found out
about Brendan Fraser experts first of
knowledge on Brendan Fraser your your
fresh head well let's see how much you
know about my
Bildad Jeff Gordon NASCAR racing legend
we're going to find out who said it why
name it quit oh I don't have an audience
Lightning McQueen or real-life racing
legend Jeff Gordon which one said we're
pathetic everywhere we go we either
stink or we're good
Lightning McQueen Jeff Gordon what ha ha
ha what context no context given I feel
like it takes a lot to get me bad but I
still get mad lately I haven't been
afraid to show it
Jeff Gordon again I am speed one winner
42 losers I losers for breakfast oh god
I hoped oh I don't know which way I hope
I hope that's not a movie that or a line
that was written by someone but I don't
think it's a thing a human said so I'm
going to say my name McQueen Lightning
McQueen
I'm killing it my IQ is dropping by the
second I'm becoming one of them I just
I'm gonna say just because I want him to
be a shady little NASCAR driver wagon
McQueen you shady ass car oh I don't
like losing and my favorite quote right
as I get older my appreciation for wine
has just increased I fell in love with
wines in my travels
um what is the name of the car that
Larry the Cable guy's plays isn't that
what no Jeff Gordon Jeff Gordon did say
that because you have his own brand of
wine that's not a plug we're not paid to
say that I just love Jeff Gordon but
Jeff you watching this you want to send
us some Lola
well drink cut on the show in our
personal time here fun fact in second
grade I left cut school for a day my
parents loved me so that I could go beat
Jeff Gordon because I was such a big
campus and oh so all those quotes were
things he said to you yes oh yeah you
didn't say that in like an interview or
anything greater than Reiki great moving
on I got Fred Jeff Gordon moving on
we're going on rough night
I'm excited about rough night hey what
happens when you mix the hangover and
bridesmaids
a murder like a coke field murder it
looks old murder
essentially the plot of rough night
which has insane cats Scarlett Johansson
Kate McKinnon Jillian Bell Ilana Glazer
hello zoe kravitz am I missing anybody
there's some dudes in it but who cares
who cares because look at these women oh
my god excited what are you most excited
for who are you most excited to see in
rough night
I love Ilana Glazer I love scarred oh I
love Kate I love all of them but mostly
I think that Jillian Bell is a superstar
in the making yes yes yes I am glad that
Ilana Glazer is becoming a movie star as
she should be broad city back later this
summer everyone tune in this is not a TV
blog podcast I might figured out why I
was literally not sponsored by anybody
but if you want to sponsor us see in the
comments below I just I just can't it
hurt you can sponsor just our personal
lives I'm anyway yes so happy about
Ilana Glazer and it makes sense this
comes from the writers of broad city so
you know it's going to be funny you know
there's going to be some drugs you know
there's going to be probably some vagina
jokes that's what that's our bread and
butter we're liquid and butter and I
agree with you I am so excited to see
Jillian Bell again she's funny and
everything as she saved 22 Jump Street
oh honey no disrespect Channing
oh I love that mr. cheeto is I love that
movie but I thought she was a great
addition all right so what you seen this
weekend should what's what gets your ETA
at the movies recommendation of the week
are we going cars three or we go in
rough night well I'm gonna have to say I
guess if you have a family go ahead and
see cars three I'm gonna say the
opposite if you have children take him -
rough night see what happens
go mad put it on YouTube but I think I'm
personally I you know what I'm going
rough night I'm going rough tonight -
I'm uh I think you need some laughs
we are some Gillian Bellas over here so
we're you're uh I'm naming her fan
you're a phrase head were the bell jars
the bell Jill we love you Jill the bell
goes oh the bell Jose juba like like
bell jars but Bell Joe fell Jill's all
right on the show we're just a couple of
Bell Joe
and also I'm hoping that if cam
mackinnon keeps killing it then she'll
have enough star power to get another
ghostbusters Creed um but that's just me
anyway that's all that's all we have
today that's all we have today that's
all we have time for today
okay next week we are talking about
transformers the last night but until
then go in the comments tell us did you
see cars three did you see
rough night I'm still waiting for
someone to defend cars to to me tell me
off in the comments well
timely kindly be nice I like sensitive
Souls like subscribe add us all that
stuff thank you guys see you next week
[Music]